I stock during class because I don't
really eat a whole bunch in between they
just let you do that no honey pockets
are for oh I'm an elderly man but when I
was a youngster boy did I love my snacks
I grew up in the golden age of snacking
and I'm excited to share that with some
youths
these days have like more access to just
internet like they know what's healthy
and what's not I mean if you looked at
my sugar intake today Lucky Charms
breakfast lunch and dinner plus a
midnight snack I mean I'm living the
life that's like the actual life when I
was growing up there weren't a lot of
healthy snacks I think the closest we
got was some peanut butter on a stick of
celery and put some raisins on it called
ants on a log because if you've ever
seen ants on a log that's what it looks
like you think you'd have cooler snacks
and I had growing up maybe wow I didn't
think he would hurt isn't what you do
are you ready to eat some snacks yes
great
first up snack packs chocolate pudding
made with real milk that's reassuring
I'm not sure if you guys fully
appreciate the joys in finding one of
these bad boys in your lunchbox when you
were a kid I would never see that like a
lunch table I see a lot of like yo play
like a little like yogurt thing I feel
like everyone now is more educated on
like what goes into food a little bit
more I was a kid is just more like
whatever is cheap and fast it was kind
of it and whatever the cool is
commercial really really favorite appeal
it's part of the process I'm not too big
with them when something's like in a
package too long you can kind of taste
the packaging I don't like the texture I
know where I'll eat it so like it's
definitely not my first choice this is a
no for me yeah it's gonna be a no for me
yeah I have these at my house right now
I have yet to outgrow these next up
candy snacks
these are one of my absolute favorites I
have a documented love for these oh my
god that smell it doesn't smell like
cheese it just smells like this snack
these were popular because in first
grade there was this a bully named JD
Pickett
it tastes fake well it's not well it's
not real describe to me the
rollercoaster of flavor emotions you're
experiencing right now it's crispy and
like the liquidy
this is quality it's good it's also my
favorite you can't stop eating it I wear
them I can't which is better these or
seaweed chips Oh No next up yogurt the
yogurt walking around with I remember
when these were in the hot new
technology in the yogurt world I spent
10 years of my life avoiding yogurt then
a commercial comes on the television it
tells me that there's go-gurt I used to
have these a lot but this is probably
gonna be like the first time I've had
one in like four years I love this
there's like always a little corner
thing those made it super easy to tear
open oh it doesn't great right yeah yeah
just like I remembered all those two
years ago I think it's delicious taste
it almost like strawberry I don't hate
it which is a plus they're still amazing
and the tube makes them better I think
if they were like a cup there wouldn't
be as good I just realized that it's by
a yellow plate it's all the same stuff
man
I just put it in the - oh it's at I'm
not pizza but pizza Lunchables cool boy
you are in for a treat today this is my
favorite probably of all my childhood
snacks my mom never really bought these
much for us it's not like a big help
but you'd ask for these and she'd be
like Oh get them for you but why is oh
my god it smells like nostalgia I just
remember the sauce being so messy the
cheese always tasted strange are you
guys excited to try this one yeah I
don't eat pepperoni because I'm
vegetarian yeah I don't you pepperoni
either because I'm vegetarian civ I
loved eating it cold so we'll just pass
this down and we'll do some some sauce
and cheese that good also more pepperoni
for me are you making a little smiley
face the smiley faces wants to be
demolished there's anything about the
idea of this grocery oh yeah and like
putting like marinara sauce on pita
bread donuts for me there's narrow is
also like I don't like a package yeah
feels rubbery yep you guys can have all
the cheese I'm just gonna go sauce and
tell you know your tastes like rubber
but like in a good way
I'm not a fan I'm sorry I don't know
it's all right better than I expected
but not great it doesn't taste like
pizza but Lunchables isn't supposed to
you know and I'm okay with this it works
right it's delicious
it's like assembling a pizza event like
not putting it in the oven I'm out of my
body right now I mean a child again it's
one of those things I'm so bad it's good
so is this something that you guys would
ever voluntarily eat again no oh yes oh
oh oh I'm sorry one more time
Oh Lord what do you say I'll finish it
oh you're gonna say but only because I
haven't had dinner yet
and I'm really hungry Oh
one thing I've noticed that that's
clearly different from your generation
to ours is that we like our like spice
you like different flavors BAM talking
cornerstone of youth education really
spicy dress oh oh I didn't know they
were rolled up like that yeah they're
like rolled tortilla chips as someone
who hates sweets and is more a fan and
salty vise yeah I am delighted to see
this much seasoning on them I've got
these five bags of these lime and spice
going to finish so would you are you all
right too much toffee what do you guys
think of 90 snacks they weren't bad I
had one good one they just felt a little
bit cardboard ish but then you have your
go girl thought I wanted sleeves like a
throwback it tastes so good I don't
think he would have been happy in my
youth whatever I feel like I would have
gotten tired of it
I don't want to try your generation okay
thanks maybe well no because we have
them so do you guys feel like you are
healthier like before you eat a snack do
you actually look at the label and I'm
like what am I about to eat I feel like
parents are on the child a lot more now
we know what we're supposed to eat and
they kind of expect us to make the right
choice I'm sure I'm not gonna make the
right choice all the time we like that
fun for kids yeah you can balance it out
for every cookie we to carry no but you
know one day we'll have more vegetables
than cookies that's incredible because I
gotta say when I was younger I don't
think any of us were paying any
attention to what we were eating we were
like we're kids we'll just eat crap but
obviously can't go wrong with your lucky
charm
we keep bringing that up I love it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]